[Music]
for many years
they had been um saying no there's no
problem
one almost felt it was sort of women
being patted on the head and said
they're there dear don't worry you know
you're imagining it or it's it's not you
don't know we know better than you do
we need real leadership uh right now we
should have a president who
is using his bully pulpit to condemn the
fatal shooting that happened
uh last night we should not see military
tanks in riot gear cops and riot gear
on the streets rush around their hair on
fire saying oh my god
i mean this is this is a new discovery
and the museum is discovering things all
the time and they're going to be more
things
that are going to be happening in here
that some people are going to be
screaming about but that's
the museum learning rehearsals stopped a
week before the show
many many months ago and the only reason
we were allowed to return and
specifically rehearse is because we were
tested so
um every morning we have a swab either
in the nose or the throat
and then that we get a wristband and
then that means you know we're negative
for that day
[Music]
now the former prime minister theresa
may is urging the government to consider
redress for the victims of the pregnancy
test drug primidos
in an exclusive interview with sky news
mrs may identified the scandal as one
example of the burning injustices
she vowed to tackle when taking back
power in 2016.
she claimed victims who said the drug
caused their children birth defects
weren't listened to properly
and were essentially patted on the head
a new film documents a sky news
investigation
and a 40-year battle by campaigners
against
pharmaceutical giant all about a pill
called primidos
used as a pregnancy test in the 1960s
and 70s
which parents believed caused
malformations to their babies
in the womb an untold part of that story
is the role of a former prime minister
does the prime minister agree with me
that those families do now deserve
justice
and there should be a chance to launch a
public inquiry into this terrible
scandal
prime minister my honourable friend has
raised an important issue
theresa may called for a review into
primitos after pressure from her own mps
and after reading a scientific review in
2017 which had found there wasn't a link
between the drug and malformations but
she felt didn't make a convincing case
certainly when i looked at the report i
felt that it wasn't the
slam dunk answer that people had had
said it was
i explained to within my number 10 team
that i think that we do should
look at this we should have a review on
this ultimately if the prime minister
decides it should go ahead then it will
go ahead
did you get any pushback well i don't
think
those around the the healthcare system
were too pleased at the idea that there
was going to be some further work on
this and
on other issues uh because for many
years
they had been um saying no there's no
problem
one almost felt it was sort of women
being patted on the head and said
they're there dear don't worry you know
you're imagining it or it's it's not you
don't know we know better than you do
in july the cumberland review team found
that there was
avoidable harm caused by a failure to
regulate primitives
their report said victims should get a
government apology
and funding from the state and
manufacturer
reading it left lead campaigner mary
lyon almost speechless
that's more that i expected
it's incredible that somebody that like
murray lyon
and other campaigners have held fast to
this campaign
despite all the many uh potential
setbacks they've had in terms of
of the uh government and and healthcare
professionals
trying to stop them in their tracks
would you have any messages to the
manufacturer well i think they need to
perhaps to look
at the history of this at the time that
primados was
still being prescribed and people were
still taking primo loss
that there was a known risk a known
potential risk
uh and ask themselves whether it
was right for that to have carried on
this prime minister will be remembered
for troubled brexit negotiations and
internal party battles over the eu
but she'll hope this and other inquiries
into hillsborough
child sexual abuse and contaminated
blood will also be part of her legacy
well we're joined now by nikki gubbins
her mother took primidos during her
pregnancy
and uh promedo's campaign campaign is
charlotte fencing
her brother stephen has severe epilepsy
and she and her family care for him very
good evening to you both
thanks for joining us we also heard from
theresa may they're talking about the
issue of redress
and we've seen campaigners in the states
getting millions of pounds
in all of this and i just wonder how you
feel whether or not it is even possible
to compensate for what you've been
through what your mother's been through
what
uh charlotte and her family have been
through
and well known of money
can make up the suffering and pains and
what we what i've been through the
family and
all the other families and wrong
um i mean the history of those that
we've had children that have now passed
away um obviously a low amount of money
would compensate for that um
but i think the there is more of
like ensuring that nothing like this
happens again
i saw you nodding along uh sincerely
there
when it comes to redress surely
compensation
would go a long way for your family
where you're having to do
round-the-clock care
and pay for that
it would i mean redress is very
important to us but i'd like to make
a distinction between redress and
compensation with pots of cash we are
not looking for
a lavish lifestyle and a bank account
full of money this
this won't bring my brother's life back
it won't give his brain back it won't
give my parents the life that they have
lost over the last 52 years caring for
essentially a 52 year old baby
[Music]
extensive medical tests are being
carried out on russia's opposition
leader alexey navalny following claims
he became seriously ill after drinking a
cup of tea
laced with poison the prominent critic
of president putin arrived in germany a
few hours ago
to receive specialist treatment after
falling into a coma on thursday
let's speak to marina lipvinenko she's
the widow of alexander liplinenko and he
was killed
after being poisoned by radioactive
polonium
in a central london hotel thank you so
much for talking to us
this afternoon it must be particularly
difficult for you to watch what's
happening at the moment
what was your first thought when you
heard about
mr navalny getting sick on that plane
first of all when i heard it two days
ago of course it was very devastating
alexey navalny was very active and very
critical to
russian regime but he escaped from
very serious damages he was arrested he
spent a lot of time in custody
like 10 days 15 days but it was not
so much serious of course his brother
was arrested
and spent a few years in prison
but alexander was more or less
safe and when i heard this news i was
very shocked
thought when there were reports that
he's been taken ill on a plane
flying um to uh moscow
was that your initial thought
no first of all uh if you're talking
about how it's all happened he was
traveling from
siberia cities tomsk to moscow
and what happened to him it was so
unexplained
and plain need to be lent it just
emergency in another city
siberian city olmsk when he was stayed
for
two days but everybody understood it was
a very dangerous situation
because nobody believed he would be
treated
in the right way and now he might be a
little bit safe
because we know he is transported to
germany to berlin
and now he's under control of german
doctors
and this is a little bit easy to talk
about this situation
but i don't think we need to be relaxed
because we still don't know what
happened to alexey
yet what do you make of the doctor at
the obsc um
hospital saying that it was something to
do with blood sugar
even more they say it is metabolic
disease
it's a quite strange of course it may be
symptoms like that
but i don't think is the reason why
alexey became
so extremely ill because of that
what doctors said again i can't be very
critical to them but
i don't think there'll be so much
freedom to say what they don't know
or if you're going back to my story
my husband alexander was treated in
hospital here in uk
and almost for two weeks but he would
recognize
he was poisoned by radioactive material
should i blame british doctors
not of course because nobody before was
poisoned by rather active
polonium and now we don't know what
happened to alexey
and as soon we will know what happened
to him and what a
poison or what the agent was used
against him we could discuss
what as a level of order i mean who
wanted to stop him
to neutralize or even to kill and
maybe we will see would be able
doctors in russia to recognize what
happened to alexey
on a personal note for you mourinho it
must be difficult
to watch what's happening to navalny at
the moment
the the most of what i do feel is for
a family of alexey navalny his wife
his children and his parents
a teenager has been arrested after two
people were shot dead during another
night
of black lives matter protests in
wisconsin the protests followed the
shooting of a black man
in the state it happened on the third
day of
unrest after jacob blake was shot seven
times
on sunday in the city of kenosha joining
me now from washington
is kristin clark president and executive
director of the lawyers committee
for civil rights under law and kristin
we look at what happens has happened
over the last three nights how concerned
are you that the violence could well
continue this evening
oh i'm deeply concerned the crisis of
police violence and racial violence has
been literally
tearing at the fabric of our nation we
have people who have been
insistently marching and protesting and
demanding reforms
and those efforts have fallen flat
congress has yet to pass a bill that
would respond
to the deadly shooting of george floyd
brianna taylor and so many others
and here we are now in the wake of the
fatal
uh not yet fatal but the the horrendous
shooting of jacob blake
what deeply concerns me here is that
people
have the right to protest and to
demonstrate at moments like these and
express
their outrage and last night in kenosha
wisconsin we saw what appeared to be
white vigilantes who were patrolling the
streets
with automatic weapons and they're now
two people who have lost their lives
a man has been placed under arrest but
we don't know whether
this shooting was racially motivated
but what we basically are seeing is the
collision
of police violence racial violence and
white supremacy all
coming to a head in our country we
we of course were down there uh last
night and and today
and and some of those who were out on
the street said that they were out there
because they were concerned
about looting and violence towards their
property we
saw our reporter there on a car lot
where the windows had been smashed on
the vehicles
um why are people concerned that that
their
properties are going to be damaged if
they are concerned haven't they got a
right to go out and defend their
property
we should be deeply concerned about loss
of life
we should be deeply concerned about the
assaults perpetrated time and time again
on unarmed black people and other
citizens
in our country people are marching and
protesting and demonstrating and they
have a right to
under our constitution there is no
right to the violent vigilantism that we
have been seeing in response
we know that the law enforcement had
been out to
protect property uh but instead what we
saw were armed
individuals with ar-15s and
automatic weapons patrolling the streets
and there are now two people dead
and at least one person injured and
this no doubt marks a crisis in our
country
and we are a nation on fire we are a
country that has yet
to reckon with the bitter ugliness of
police violence and racial violence
that has gripped the nation where
do we go from here how can the heat be
taken out of this
we need real leadership right now we
should have a president
who is using his bully pulpit to condemn
the fatal shooting that happened last
night
right now is a moment where we should
not see military tanks in riot gear cops
and riot gear
on the streets because that has been
proven to inevitably escalate
tensions the public is grieving the
public is
tormented by a man jacob blake
unarmed who was shot in front of his
three
children while going into his car they
have
a right under the constitution to speak
out to demonstrate
and protest that should be respected
we need to de-escalate the law
enforcement presence
and we need our congress to get to work
to put in place the strong
reforms that are needed to address
police violence which
has beleaguered our nation for far too
long
[Music]
after more than 23 weeks shut due to the
coronavirus pandemic the british museum
has reopened its doors to visitors
today there have however been some
changes both in health
health and safety precautions and what
is
on show joining me now is the former
british museum trustee bonnie greer
hello to you
at bonnie grier han sloan bust
what's happened
what's happened with with what sloane
yes
with sloane that the bastard of of han
sloan the founding father of
the british museum where is he oh right
okay we took him off the pedestal and
put him in a case
with all his goods and i helped wright
rewrite the narrative about him because
you know he got his money
to be able to start the collection of
the british museum
and the british library and the natural
history museum by the way
through the slave trade so the museum
wants to reflect that
and it's the beginning of a process
where the museum is going to look at
everything and really on the first level
start to tell
different stories and fuller stories so
that's what happened to him well he's
still around he's just like with his
stuff now
yeah so it's not about removing him but
you describe it as rewriting the
narrative putting
his place into context
yeah i mean he's you know he's here so
all the people are screaming about it
you know they're wrong he's in here
except now we're saying and then he did
this and this is where he got that and
this is where he got this and this is
where he got this and this is how he got
that and this is
so that that's what a museum is kind of
for
is to tell you information like that and
let you think about it so that's what
we're doing but you're still here
it comes doesn't it in the week when
we've had a the row about
last night of the proms rule britannia
uh boris johnson saying that
we've got to stop this cringing
embarrassment about our history and he
described it a fight of
self-recrimination
and wetness is that what this is part of
well look you know from my point of view
it's called education
nobody's embarrassed about anything i
mean when you find out something
you relate to it you react to it i mean
that's really what's happening
you find out more and more information
that's what a museum does it gets
smarter and smarter and smarter
and then it adjusts itself that's life
and for people to sort of rush around
their hair on fire saying oh my god
i mean this is this is a new discovery
and the museum is discovering things all
the time and they're going to be more
things
that are going to be happening in here
that some people are going to be
screaming about but that's
the museum learning and that's the
museum responding
to its own learning and as a public
facing institution
the museum has to listen to people too
not do what they say
but listen and so it's a dynamic process
and we got a great director who's
totally involved in that
i'm doing a project with him called the
era of reclamation that's part of that
and
the museum is going to adjust itself as
it learns
and that's what it's about as it learns
and that's what's exciting about being
here now
musical theater is on its way out of
lockdown
among the first shows where the curtain
goes up will be sleepless
a musical starring the singer jamie
guinness from the boy band the wanted
here's just a sneak preview
she had everything she wanted
without asking life would bring
if she wanted gently waking you can't
bet the birds would sing
should she want a little sugar
to sweeten up her tea i'd make it even
sweeter
perching jonah on her knee
still got the pipes doesn't he at j
mcginnis i'm pleased to say
jones is now on the programme jay really
good to see you this morning um
let's start by just telling us a little
bit about the musical itself
sleepless based on sleepless in seattle
and tom hanks those are some shoes to
fill
yeah that's right it's uh it's tom hanks
and meg ryan uh who also did
uh not to be mixed with you've got mail
um but i
i and kimberly while she was also in the
show both have a little bit of
history with tom hanks movies becoming
musicals we did big
um last year two years ago at the
dominion theatre so
yeah we have a little bit of experience
with that and we've really enjoyed
turning it into a big jazzy number
so how have you guys been able to kind
of come together
to rehearse to do the technical
rehearsals in a time of
a viral pandemic there must have been
some practicalities that you had to deal
with
yeah there are actually quite a lot um
obviously rehearsals stopped a week
before the show
many many months ago and the only reason
we were allowed to return and
specifically rehearse
is because we were tested so um every
morning we have a swab either in the
nose or the throat
and then that we get a wristband and
then that means you know we're negative
for that day
and aside from that testing which means
that we can get close for you know
brief moments on stage when it's
necessary um
we then also have the regular stuff so
wearing face masks
whenever we're not on stage one-way
systems washing our hands
and socially distancing and we invite
our audience to
socially distance and follow all those
rules as well how confident
are you that you know theater land is
ready to open its doors that it
it is fully aware of the risks involved
in bringing large numbers of people
together in
in one enclosed space well i think i'm
not hugely confident i just know that it
can happen in very specific
circumstances and
and we need to try and spread those
circumstances across the board
i think a lot of smaller theaters
struggle especially the older ones have
tiny corridors and
that's a really hard problem to overcome
maybe across the country newer buildings
will be able to do that and i think the
old the older buildings
if they're gonna you know be able to
confidently invite audiences back
i really think they'll probably have to
be huge investment on maybe removing
some
seating and making bar areas bigger
because
if we do have to be socially distanced
for many years to come and maybe
different pandemics in the future
theaters just stop
[Music]